the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay now clustering for graphs so this
is a topic this is one of the important
things you can try to do with a graph so
you have a large graph let me kind of
divide it into two clusters okay so you
get a giant graph and then the job is to
make some sense out of it and one
possible step is to be able to subdivide
it if as I see here there's a cut
between two reasonably equal parts of
the graph reasonably reasonably same
size and therefore that graph could be
studied in two pieces so the question is
how do you find such a cut by a by a
algorithm what's an algorithm that would
find that cut so the so that's a problem
let's say we're looking for two four
four two clusters we could look for more
clusters but let's say we want to look
for two clusters so what are we trying
to do we're trying to minimize so this
is the problem then so we look for find
positions x and y let's say two which
will be the center's so to speak of the
and really it's just these points yeah
that so that the data is the points and
the edges as always the nodes and the
edges though so the problem is to find x
and y so that to minimize
so it's a distance of points AI from X
maybe should emphasize we're in high
dimensions plus the distance of other
points so the AI will be these points
these nodes and the bi will be these
nodes plus the sum of BI minus y squared
and you understand the rule here that
the together the the A's Union the bees
give me all nodes and I guess to be
complete the a's the a's intersect the
bees is empty just just what you expect
I'm dividing the A's and the B's into
two groups and I'm picking an x and a y
sort of at the center of those groups so
that that is a minimum so I want to
minimize and also I probably want to
impose some condition that the number of
A's is reasonably close to the number of
bees in other words I don't want just
that to be the a and all the rest to be
the bees that would be not a
satisfactory clustering I'm looking for
clusters that are good sized clusters so
minimize that okay so there are a lot of
different algorithms to do it some are
more directly attacking this problem
others use matrices that we associate
with the graph so let me tell you about
two or three
those algorithms and and you if you've
seen studied had a course in graph
theory this you may already have seen
this problem first question would be
suppose I decide these are the A's and
those are the bees or some other
decision yeah probably some other
decisions I don't want to solve the
problem before I even start
so some A's and some B's what would be
the best choice of the X once you've
decided on the A's and what would be the
best choice of the Y once you've decided
on the B's so so that we can answer that
question just if we knew the the two
groups we could see where they should be
centered with the first group centered
at X the second group centered at Y and
what is centering me so let's just say
so I think what I'm saying here is so
given the a's the a's this is a one up
to say a k what is the best is the best
x to just to make that part right and
the answer is do do you know
geometrically what X should be here X is
the so if I have a bunch of points and
I'm looking for the middle of those
points the point X a good point X to say
okay that's the middle it'll make the
sum of the distances I think squared I
hope I'm right about that
a minimum what's the what is X it is the
the centroid centroid is the word X is
the centroids
of the of the A's and what is the
centroid let's see well maybe I don't
know if x and y we're a good choice but
look let me see what I guess it's the
average a it's the sum of the A's of
these A's those are those are vectors of
course divided by the number of A's I
think actually I was just quickly
reviewing this morning so I'm not
totally on top of this centroid what I'm
going to talk the algorithm that I'm
going to talk about is the K well K
means it's always called and here it
will be the K will be two I just have
two partitioning into two sets a and B
so I just K is just 2 okay what's the
algorithm well if if I've chosen a
partition the A's and the B's have
separated them then that tells me what
the X and the y should be but now what
do I do next so is this going to be a
sort of an alternating partition now I
take those two centroids so so step one
is forgiven YZ and B's find their
centroids X and what and that elementary
then the second step is given the
centroids x and y given those positions
given x and y they won't be centroids
once when you see what happens given x
and y
we do we form form the best partition
best clusters okay so step one we we had
a guess at what the best clusters were
and we found their centroids now we
start with the centroids and we form new
clusters again and if these clusters are
the same as the ones we started with
with them then the algorithm has
converged but probably won't be these
clusters so you'll have to tell me what
what I mean by the best clusters if I'm
if I've got the two points x and y I
want the points I want to separate all
the points that cluster around X to the
ones that cluster around Y and then they
probably different from my original
start so now I've got new now I repeat
step one so but let's just think how do
i form the best clusters well I take a
point and I have to decide does it go
with X or does it go with in the X
cluster or does it go in the cluster
around Y so how do I decide that just
whichever one is closer to so each each
point goes with each node you should I I
could say each node goes with the the
closer of x and y
so points that should have been that are
closer to X now we're going to put them
in the cluster around X and does that
solve the problem
no because well it might but it might
not the we have to come back to step one
we've now changed their clusters they'll
have different centroids so we repeat
step one find their centroids for the
two new clusters then we come to step
two find the ones that should go with
the two centroids and back and forth I
don't know I don't think there's a nice
theory of convergence or rate of
convergence all the questions that this
course is always asking but it's a very
popular algorithm k-means K would be to
have K clusters okay so that's a I'm not
going to discuss the I'd rather discuss
some other ways to do this to solve this
problem but that's one sort of hack that
works quite well okay so second approach
is is what it's coming next second
solution method and it's called the
spectral clustering
that's the name of the method and before
I write down what you do what does the
word spectral mean you see spectral
graph theory spectral clustering and in
other parts of mathematics you see that
where you see spectral theorem I gave
you the most and I described it as the
most important perhaps theorem in linear
algebra at least one of the top three is
so I'll write it over here because it's
not it doesn't this is a it's the same
word spectral well let me ask the
question again what's that word spectral
about what does that mean that means
that if I have a matrix and I want to
talk about its spectrum what is the
spectrum of the matrix it is the the
eigenvalues so spectral theory spectral
clustering is using the eigenvalues of
some matrix that's what that spectral is
telling me yeah so the spectral theorem
of course is that for a symmetric matrix
s the eigenvalues are real and the
eigenvectors are orthogonal and don't
forget what the real full statement is
here because there could be repeated
real eigenvalues and what does the
spectral theorem tell me for symmetric
matrices if that if lambda equal five is
repeated four times if it's a four times
solution of the equation that gives
eigenvalues then what's the conclusion
then there are four independent
orthogonal I
vectors to go with it we can't say that
about matrices
about all matrices but we can say it
about all symmetric matrices and in fact
those eigenvectors are orthogonal so
we're even saying more we can find for
orthogonal eigenvectors that go with a
with a multiplicity for eigenvalues okay
that's spectral theorem spectral
clustering starts with the with the
graph laplacian matrix may I remember
what that matrix is because that's the
that's the key connection of linear
algebra to graph theory is the
properties of this graph laplacian
matrix okay so let me say L for
laplacian so that matrix one way to
describe it is as a transpose a where a
is the incidence matrix of the graph or
another way we'll see is two is the D
the degree matrix that's diagonal
and I'll do an example just to remind
you - the I don't know what I've called
this one shall I call it B for the
moment and what matrix is B that's the
adjacency matrix really you should know
these four matrices they're the key four
matrices associated with any graph the
incidence matrix that's M by n row edges
and nodes edges and nodes so it's
rectangular but I'm forming a transpose
ru here so I'm forming a symmetric
positive semi definite matrix
so this this little blossom is symmetric
positive semi definite yeah let me let
me just recall what all these matrices
are for for a simple graph
okay so I'll just draw a graph alright
okay so the incidence matrix there are 1
2 3 4 5 edges so 5 rows there are 4
nodes 1 2 3 and 4 so 4 columns and a
typical row would be edge 1 going from
node 1 to node 2 so it would have a
minus 1 and a 1 there and let me take
its two going from 1 to node 3 so we'd
have a minus 1 and a 1 there so so
that's the incidence matrix a ok what's
the degree matrix that's simple
the degree matrix well a transpose a
this is M by n this is n by M so it's
it's n by n ok in this case 4 by 4 so
the degree matrix will be 4 by 4 and by
him and it will tell us the degree of
that which means which we just count the
edges so it's 3 edges going in no 2 3
edges going in node 3 has just 2 edges
and node 4 has just 2 edges it so that's
the degree matrix and then the adjacency
matrix that I've called B is also 4 by 4
and what is it it tells us which node is
connected to which node so and I don't
allow nodes edges
that connect an O to itself so zeros on
the diagonal
how many so which nodes are connected to
node one well all of two and four and
three are connected to one so I have
ones there no to all three nodes are
connected - no - so I'll have the second
column and row will have all three ones
how about no three okay only only edges
only two edges are connected only to
only two nodes are connected to three
one and two but not four so one and two
I have but not four okay so that's the
adjacency matrix is that right think so
this is the degree matrix this is the
incidence matrix and that formula gives
me the laplacian okay let's just write
down the laplacian so if I use the
degree minus B that that's easy the
degrees were 3 3 2 & 2 now I have these
minuses and those those were 0 ok
so that's a positive semi-definite
matrix is it a positive definite matrix
so we'll let me ask you is it singular
or is it not singular
is there a vector in its null space or
is there not a vector in its null space
can you solve d x equals all zeroes and
of course you can everybody sees that
the vector of all ones will be a
solution to D to 2l I'm sorry I should
be saying L here L x equals 0 L x equals
0 for a whole line of a one-dimensional
and the null space of L is has dimension
1 it's got one basis vector 1 1 1 1 and
that will always happen with a with a
with the graph set up that I've created
ok so that's the first fact that this
positive semi definite matrix L as
lambda 1 equals 0 and the eigenvector is
constant cccc the one-dimensional eigen
space or 1 1 1 1 is a typical
eigenvector ok now back to graph
clustering the idea of graph a graph
clustering is to look at the Fiedler
eigen vector this is called X 2 is the
next eigenvector is the
the eigenvector for the smallest
positive eigenvalue for lambda min
excluding 0 so the smallest eigenvalue
of l the smallest eigenvalue and its
eigenvector this is called the Fiedler
vector named after the Czech
mathematician a great great a great man
in linear algebra and he studied this
vector this situation so everybody who
knows about the graph laplacian is aware
that its first eigenvalue is zero and
that the next eigenvalue is is important
yeah
to Laplace's equation yes so yeah that's
a good question so why the word the name
laplacian so-so
yeah that's a good question so the
familiar thing so it connects to
Laplace's finite difference equation
because we're talking about matrices
here and not derivatives not functions
so why the word laplacian well so if I
have a regular if my graph is composed
of so there's a graph with with 25 nodes
and 4 times 5 20 about 40 this is
probably has about 40 edges and 25 nodes
and of course I can construct its graph
all those four matrices for it it's it's
incidence matrix its degree matrix of
the degree will be for at all these
inside points the degree will be 3 at
these boundary points the degree will be
2 at these corner points but the what
will the matrix L look like so so what
is L and that will tell you why it has
this name laplacian so the matrix L will
have the degree 4 right will be on the
diagonal that's coming from D the other
the minus ones that come from be the
adjacency matrix will be associated with
those nodes and otherwise all zeros so
this is a typical row of L
typical role of Elle centered at that
node so maybe that's node number five 10
13 that's 13 out of 25 that would would
show you this and that sorry those are
minus ones minus ones so a 4 a 4 in the
on the diagonal and 4 minus ones that's
the model problem for when the graph is
a grid square grid and do you associate
that with Laplace's equation so this is
the this is the reason that the Laplace
why why the plus gets in it because
Laplace's equation the differential
equation is second derivative with
respect to x squared and the second
derivative the special y squared is 0
and what we have here is L u equals 0
it's discrete laplacian the vector
laplacian the graph laplacian where the
second X derivative is replaced by minus
1 to minus 1 and the second Y derivative
is replaced by minus 1 to minus 1 second
differences in the X and the y
directions so that's yeah so that's the
that's the explanation for laplace it's
a discrete laplace discrete or the
finite difference Laplace okay now to
finish I have to tell you what the what
clusters how do you decide the clusters
from L how does L propose two clusters
the A's and the B's and and here's the
answer they come from this eigenvector
the fiedler eigenvectors you look at
that eigenvector
it's got some positive and some negative
components the components with positive
numbers of this eigenvector so the
positive the positive components of X so
of this yeah of this eigenvector and
there are negative components of this
eigenvector and those are the two
clusters so there so it's the cluster is
the two clusters are decided by the
eigenvector by the signs plus or minus
signs of the components the plus signs
going 1 and the minus signs go into
another and you have to experiment to
see that that would succeed I don't know
what it would do on this actually
because that's hardly splits up into two
I suppose maybe the split is along a
line like that or something to to get I
don't know what clustering that's that
this is not a graph that is naturally
clustered but you could still do two
k-means on it you could still do
spectral clustering and you would find
this eigenvector now what's the point
about this eigenvector there I'll finish
in one moment what do we know about that
eigenvector as compared to that one so
here was an eigenvector all ones let me
just make it all one one one one one in
that picture it's 25 ones here's a the
next eigenvector up and what's the
relation between those two eigenvectors
of L they are orthogonal
these are eigenvectors of a symmetric
matrix so they're orthogonal so that
means to be orthogonal to this guy
means that your components added to zero
right a vector is orthogonal to all ones
that dot product is just add up the
components so we have a bunch of
positive components and a bunch of
negative components they have the same
sum because because the dot product with
that is zero and those two components
those two sets of components are your to
tell you the two clusters in spectral
clustering so it's a pretty nifty
algorithm it does ask you to compute an
eigen vector and that of course takes
time and then there's a third more
direct algorithm to to do this
optimization problem well actually there
are many this is an important problem so
there are many proposed algorithms good
okay I'm closing up there was a final
question yeah well certainly for k-means
now if i had to do three clusters with
fiedler i would look at the first three
eigenvectors and well the first one
would be nothing and i would look at the
next two and that would be pretty
successful if I wanted six clusters it
probably would fall off in in the
quality of the the clustering yeah but
that certainly I would look at the
lowest six eigenvectors and get
somewhere yeah right so okay so that's a
topic important topic I sort of standard
topic in applied graph theory okay so
say your Wednesday I'm hoping I'm hoping
on Wednesday so professor Adelman has
told me a new and optimal way to look at
the problem of back propagation you
remember back propagation if you
remember the lecture on it you don't
don't you don't want to remember the
lecture on it it
it's it's a tricky messy thing to
explain but he says if I explain it
using Julia in linear algebra it's it's
clear so we'll give him a chance on
Wednesday to show that that
revolutionary approach to to the
explanation of back propagation and I
hope for I told him he could have half
an hour and projects would take some
time I hope now we've had to with wild
applause so I hope we get a couple more
in our last class okay see you Wednesday
and if you bring well if you have
projects ready send them to me online
and maybe a printout as well that would
be terrific if you don't have them ready
by the hour they can go the envelope
outside my office would receive them
good so I'll see you Wednesday for the
final class